Joker is dividing the heck out of
audiences far and wide including one
very significant crowd Oscar voters The
Hollywood Reporter recently spoke with a
number of members of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences and
like critics and audiences they were
largely split on the film first let's
hear from the crowd that loved it
one male member of these members at
large branch who saw the film at the
official Academy screening noted that
the flick was well received by the 500
audience members and said I think it's
brilliant
Joaquin Phoenix has never been better I
thought that the director of photography
production designer and others created
the look and feel of the period really
well and the fact that it has very
contemporary themes of economic class
and equalities just felt right
overall a home run a female member of
the same branch agreed although she
admitted that her quote stomach was
still churning the day after viewing the
film she added it made me uncomfortable
from the very first frame to the last
but I thought the movie was
extraordinary it's the most outstanding
performance I've seen in many years it's
still early but I can certainly see
myself nominating it for Best Picture
and Phoenix has to get nominated or the
actors branch doesn't know what it's
doing a male member of the Writers
branch compared the film favorably to
the last picture to score an Oscar win
for an actor playing Joker saying I
thought the filmmaking was exceptional
certainly the most innovative superhero
movie since the Dark Knight I haven't
seen any of the seasons academy movies
yet but artistically I think this film
is stronger than many of last year's
Oscar nominated films then there was one
male member of the producers branch who
boldly predicted that the Joker will
deliver come February saying I loved it
and it will win Best Picture I am really
bored with all the superhero movies but
here I really liked it because it's a
great movie before it's a genre movie to
say that many of the Oscar voters who
spoke with The Hollywood Reporter were
not quite so impressed would be a
massive understatement
those who disliked the film disliked it
intensely and they didn't hold back when
discussing what they perceived to be
Joker's faults one female member of the
executive branch while praising
Phoenix's work simply couldn't puzzle
out the point of the movie she said
strange depressing film I was vaguely
Mesmer
but to what end I found it severely
lacking any specific thematic point
great performance and impressive
filmmaking but a rather unpleasant
experience overall one male member of
the directors branch called the film a
cynical mess one that was not so much
influenced by the works of Martin
Scorsese as it was derivative of his
works he said I also found it to be more
than a bit irresponsible in terms of its
depiction of both mental illness and
violence it also seems the film was made
only to provoke but I find it isn't
interesting enough to do that subtlety
is not the director or lead actors
strong suit here finally I found the
film to be a big disappointment and one
filled with self-importance a male
member of the documentary branch stated
that while the film was admittedly well
made he found it downright irresponsible
of the filmmakers to unleash it upon a
world in which unhinged male loners
seemingly perpetrate violence every
other day he said who knows what effect
it will have on some deranged sociopath
in today's climate of gun violence
bottom line
technically an interesting experimental
genre film that presents a socially
dicey spectacle that I found personally
repugnant
although most Oscar voters opinions came
down firmly on one side of the fence or
the other there was a distinct minority
that fell into the undecided camp one
male member of the producers branch was
befuddled as to how he should vote even
though he personally loved the film he
explained I don't see any reason why
this movie should be out in the universe
there is nothing in it that starts a
conversation it just pours lighter fluid
on a conversation that's staring us in
the face every week I don't know if it
should be banned or if it should be
given every award another male member of
the same branch was blown away but the
film's technical merits but nevertheless
found it literally too difficult to
watch due to its subject matter saying I
found the craft to be stunning on every
level beautiful photography design
costumes but I deeply despise the movie
we had to drink away our discomfort it
was the first movie in history that was
too dark for me based on all these
comments it seems like Joker has a
roughly 50/50 chance of scoring an Oscar
win and its strongest chance seems to be
in the Best Actor category with a good
number of Oscar voters on its side
though it's possible that the flick
could score nominations for its
direction incentive
TACA fee for which it has received
pretty consistent praise they could even
buck the odds to score a Best Picture
nomination and if it does it is not
outside the realm of possibility that it
could win at the moment one on line odds
maker has the flick dead even with
Scorsese's the Irishman as the
favourites to take home the big prize
according to bleeding cool
perhaps Joker will really get the last
laugh at the 91st Academy Awards
ceremony which takes place on February
9th 2020 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]